okay let's be real spider-man no way
home was a blast if nothing else you
have to admire a movie that brought
together three separate franchises
spanning 20 years sure end game was
impressive and all but that was always
the uh it was always the end game for
the mcu from the very beginning but here
no one could have seen this one coming
just absolutely so much fun which means
that now we have to rip this thing to
shreds because that ending man we have
gotta talk about it well the movie was
great and all peter parker's final wish
left me with a lot of questions and it
seems like i'm not the only one i mean
does the guy have a birth certificate a
social security card what happens with
all the videos and news reports about
him being spider-man so what did old
tommy holland actually wish for in the
final moments of the movie and what does
that actually translate to based on
every clue that we see in the film's
final moments and more importantly what
does it mean for the future of this
character and this franchise that my
friends is what i'm aiming to answer
today
hello internet welcome to film theory
where i use my peter tingle each and
every week to spot and solve lore
mysteries obviously get your minds out
of the gutter guys okay so spiderman no
way home really needs no introduction at
this point it seems like everyone in the
world has seen this thing probably has
actually considering that it had the
number two opening weekend of all time
of any movie ever that is insane in fact
it only took that one single weekend to
make the highest grossing movie of 2021.
after a year where theaters were really
struggling to find their footing the old
web head proved that people were willing
to come back provided you have a huge ip
pay off one of cinema's biggest
cliffhangers and tap into 20 years of
built up nostalgia you know no biggie
but this movie really does have it all
lots of bad guys come together toby
mcguire getting his back cracked great
power great responsibility all that
stuff really solid across the board but
gotta be honest here any time you tamper
with the multiverse you're gonna be
getting some questions from lore nerds
like me and this movie leaves open some
big ones questions that i aim to
definitively answer today or you know as
definitive as i can until they retcon
something to fit the ongoing narrative
that they're looking to tell first and
foremost why are we only seeing the
villains as a reminder the entire
premise of the movie kicks off when
peter parker asks doctor strange to cast
a spell that makes everyone forget that
he's spider-man after peter tampers with
the spell one too many times it breaks
the fabric of reality opening the door
for villains like lizard and dr otto
octavius to come through from other
universes because as the movie tells us
they knew the spider-man peter parker
connection at least most of them did
prompting our first major discussion
here electro is a bit hazy on this point
since in the amazing spider-man 2 max
dylan never explicitly makes the peter
parker spider-man connection in fact it
seems like no way holm acknowledges this
there's even a joke about it where
electro upon seeing andrew garfield's
face at the end of the movie says that
he'd assumed that peter parker was gonna
be black the entire time so is that just
the writers being sloppy so they can fit
in a miles morales joke or are they
actually playing some level of 4d chess
that we mere nerds aren't privy to well
there are two possible ways to explain
elektro's presence both of which require
a fair amount of squinting to make work
first we hear no way home that elektra
was and this is a direct quote from the
movie that i can't play for obvious
reasons he was stuck in the grid
absorbing data before his memory
disappears and he dies now this isn't
exactly true if you go back to the
source material electro was actually in
a power grid specifically a
hydroelectric power grid and i know
science wasn't your strongest suit
hollywood so this might come as a shock
to you but electricity is different than
the internet i know i know i was just as
blown away as you are but i guess if
you're assuming that he's absorbing
electricity and internet in this scene
then you could say that max got the info
through accessing peter's online data
maybe
like i said it's a pretty weak sauce
explanation the other angle here and
this is the one that i think is
canonical to the story and also works
with the whole i thought you'd be black
joke is that max does know spider-man's
name is peter he just doesn't know his
face in the final fight elektra is
knocked unconscious after playing the
itsy bitsy spider on the power grid
because this movie just makes all the
worst decisions gwen stacy arrives and
calls out to peter at which point we
smash cut to electro becoming alert and
ready to attack again when i say you
turn that power on you turn it on no
matter what peter so that definitely
explains how electro knows that
spider-man's name is peter but i think
that there's still a missing piece here
and that's peter's best friend harry who
breaks elektro out of captivity to help
him take care of spider-man i'm harry
osborne i want to make you a deal you
want spider-man and i can give you at
this point in the movie harry knows that
peter and spider-man share some sort of
connection you took his picture you know
him harry most likely tells all of this
to electro after he breaks him out so
when max hears the name peter from gwen
he's able to make that final connection
to peter parker harry's friend that he
was told about oh boy there you go
screenwriters i saved your butts on that
one something tells me that no one
really intended all of that but it does
manage to work out when you read between
the lines anyway putting electro aside
i'm more interested in the bigger
question why only the villains why don't
we see anyone else come through here
like girlfriends or best friends in the
sam raimi trilogy mary jane knows
peter's identity all too well go get him
tiger and in the amazing spider-man gwen
stacy treats it like it's the most
casual thing in the world consider
coming in through the lobby the best
friends in these movies also tend to
know the harry osborns from both
universes know peter's secret first
we'll see who's behind the mask
peter
so was this just a decision made out of
convenience or is there an actual
in-universe explanation for it well
believe it or not but this one actually
lines up pretty well with the lore i
don't know again if this was intentional
or not but as doctor strange prepares
his magic peter requests that his
girlfriend his best friend and aunt may
all get exempted from the spell so mj's
gonna forget about everything we've ever
been through oh my god ned my aunt may
should really stop talking it's so
strange removes them from the magic to
try and meet peter's request however
when the whole thing goes haywire and
people who knew peter's identity start
crossing over those people are still
eliminated as such all the girlfriends
best friends and ants aren't included
and therefore don't cross over into the
mcu was it intentional no probably not
is it a cool coincidence that helps
explain the rationale for that part of
the movie yeah i think so one of the
other things the movie just kind of
glosses over that i thought was
interesting to think about was the
implication of curing all of these
characters the whole second act of the
movie is peter sacrificing and losing
everything including ant-may to try and
cure these villains working under the
assumption that he's saving their lives
and giving them a second chance in their
own universes except uh nope nope that
is decidedly not true the sand man
doesn't die in his movie so kind of a
lost cause there same thing with a
lizard who already is transformed back
into a human by the end of his movie so
redundancy is redundant that leaves
electro and green goblin neither of whom
want to be cured which opens a big old
can of ethical worms about forcing a
cure on individuals that don't want to
be cured but worst of all perhaps is the
situation for doc ock who if you
actually look back at the original movie
wouldn't be saved at all in no way home
he says that he's portaled over into tom
holland's reality in the middle of a
battle against spider-man specifically
he says quote spider-man was trying to
stop my fusion reactor so i stopped him
i had him by the throat then i was here
one teeny tiny problem with that by the
time doc ock has spider-man by the
throat and spider-man 2 his fusion
reactor is already seconds away from
exploding it is far beyond the point of
saving the good doctor himself is mere
seconds away from his own redemption at
this point
listen to me now
seriously doc ock already makes the
decision to turn good and sacrifice
himself so tom holland's help with a
fixed neural implant here also amounts
to just a meaningless gesture for
something that was gonna happen anyway
in short this whole movie was extraneous
because you either don't change any
character's outcome or you just cure
people who don't wanna be cured in the
first place sorry about your sacrifice
aunt may doesn't look like you did much
good but hey at least you got to say the
iconic line but now the big one the
ending wish at the end of the movie the
green goblin uses a pumpkin bomb to
destroy the deus box machina causing
reality to shred and even more entities
to try and cross over into tom holland's
universe doctor strange tries to repair
the rift but it's just too much he can't
contain it so with no other option peter
makes one final sacrifice he asks
strange to make the world forget about
peter parker now i've rewatched the
scene a couple of times and this is
exactly how it's transcribed they're
here because of you what if everyone
forgot who i was they're coming here
because of me right because i'm peter
parker so cast a new spell but this time
make everyone forget who peter parker is
make everyone forget me that would mean
everyone who knows and loves you would
have no memory of you would be as though
you never existed and it works the rift
gets repaired and the world no longer
knows the identity of spider-man hooray
but it comes at the cost of mj ned happy
and all the others have no clue who
peter is so it's just a simple memory
wipe spell right what's so complicated
to understand about that well if only it
were that simple as peter and disney are
more than happy to remind us of
repeatedly throughout the movie peter is
the most famous person in the world at
this point because mysterio outed him as
the identity of spider-man and he did
this in the form of a video did that
video get wiped away by the spell sure
let's assume that it was but then what
about all the other physical evidence of
peter parker before the big climax peter
takes a selfie video that gets broadcast
out to the world does that disappear too
or his text messages to mj or flash's
book are those all just gone what about
his application to mit the simple answer
here would be that the spell dusted all
of those things too all physical traces
of peter parker just poof away like
doctor strange said it'll be as though
you never existed except yet again it's
not that clear cut we see in the final
scenes of the movie that mj is wearing
the broken black dahlia necklace that
peter gave her in the previous movie in
addition we learned that both ned and mj
have gotten into mit something that
peter had a direct hand in earlier in
the film so it seems like his physical
actions have had some sort of memory on
the world even if the world doesn't
necessarily remember him so maybe
peter's just gone then right everything
he touched and altered up that point
stays but anything with the name peter
parker on it's just dusted away
not again on one hand we see peter
studying for his geds for those who
don't know the ged here in the us is a
test that allows you to show that you
have high school level skills by taking
it and passing it functions pretty much
the same way as a diploma so the fact
that he's taking it implies either a
that his academic record has been erased
as part of the spell or b he isn't
returning to finish the school year
again most likely because he no longer
has a student record but on the other
hand we see peter get himself an
apartment this implies that he has to
have himself some level of an identity
as well as a fairly decent credit score
as anyone who's ever tried to get an
apartment can tell you you need a social
security number and a history of income
to be able to lease from a landlord so a
lot of conflicting information there but
of all the conflicting evidence we have
none perhaps is as confusing as his
interactions with happy at ant-may's
grave when peter asks how he knew her
happy replies through spider-man so
happy knows spider-man but again not
peter parker how could that possibly
make any sense because happy knows mei
not via spider-man but because
spider-man is connected to peter parker
without the link of peter parker there's
no way for happy to meet may and yet
somehow under the arbitrary rules of the
spell he does apparently know her which
then prompts the question does that mean
mj under the memory spell remembers
being spider-man's girlfriend because
again she knows spider-man but she
doesn't know peter same thing with ned
does he know that he's spider-man's guy
in the chair so taking all the evidence
and questions into account i think
there's only one way to explain all of
this this spell doesn't erase peter
parker from existence it just erases
people's memory of him and along with
that erases any physical thing that
would be considered or connected to a
memory of him but peter's achievements
the aftermath of thing that he's
explicitly done those all remain it's a
difference of qualitative versus
quantitative actions which is pretty
confusing so let me explain with some
examples mysterio's video claiming that
he's being attacked by spider-man that
still exists because it was tied to an
action that was being done by spider-man
but the part where he calls out peter
parker that now is gone because it would
be dependent on mysterio knowing peter
parker flash's book gone because again
it's based on flash's relationship and
memories with peter parker meanwhile
peter's bank account and social security
number those would remain earning money
and putting it into a bank or being
given a social security number are
physical acts that don't hinge on the
memory or identity of peter parker just
like giving a physical necklace to mj
she has the necklace but i would guess
she doesn't remember where she got it
from those actions exist separate from
the identity of peter basically when
people see his name they'll just think
of him as some random anonymous person
like we see mj do in the coffee shop so
what then would this mean for the series
well if i'm right it would mean that
both mg and ned shouldn't remember their
interactions with spider-man to both of
them he was peter parker first and when
they're helping spider-man they're
really helping peter so all of those
memories have gotta go happy meanwhile
is able to fall into the opposite bucket
his relationship with peter started
through the identity of spider-man and
while he certainly grew to love the boy
behind the mask the root of that
relationship was the secret identity
thus allowing him to remember aunt may
and chalk those memories up to
spider-man's influence likewise
spider-man should still be able to
continue on as an avenger but here no
one will know his real name making the
eventual reunion with the guardians of
the galaxy real awkward who are you
we're the avengers man but to me what's
probably most interesting about all this
is how it relates to the vulture as you
might recall he's the biggest dangling
threat in the series the only one who
knows spider-man's identity and who
keeps getting teased as pulling together
a sinister six this is that on you
it's on our
little spider friend i've got some boys
on the outside who'd love to meet him in
fact he's so important that he's being
used to market the upcoming morbius
movie hey dr mike you and i should stay
in touch leaving many to question
whether morbius is now a part of the mcu
and sony's response thus far has been
yesent there being real kg about it but
in reality no no he's not this is all
just a fake out by the rules that we've
just gone over the vulture wouldn't know
peter's secret identity the scene in the
current homecoming would be a forgotten
memory as such all of the teases from
both morbius and tom holland's
spider-man movies should ultimately
amount to nothing then moments in
trailers like this are just more
instances of movie studios pulling
boners that's a ralph boner for those
who don't get the reference
ralph
boner
boner all of it fake outs to sell
tickets so there you have it friends no
way home a lot of seeming gaps in the
plot that just squeak by getting solved
if you look at them deep enough well
done screenwriters you've escaped me
this time which leaves us then with a
single spider-man who has literally no
history when a nice clean slate to start
a brand new trilogy on one might call it
a reboot of sorts and wait who was it
that predicted that by whatever means
wanda maximoff zaps in during the
post-credits scene to set us up for the
multiverse of madness the story is going
to wrap up in such a way that while
there can be a path forward for tom
holland's peter parker he can also be
soft rebooted i guess sometimes even a
blind squirrel finds a nut but hey
that's just a theory a film theory
and cuts
[Music]
you